welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Seth Jacobi wits an assistant
professor of East Asian languages and
literature's at Yale University his
research focuses on the intersection of
media and literature in late 19th
century Japan today we'll talk with
Professor Jacoby wits about his recent
book writing technology in Meiji Japan a
media history of modern Japanese
literature and visual culture which won
the 2017 international convention of
Asia Scholars Book Prize in the
humanities
welcome professor Jacobo wits thank you
so much for having me so let's begin
with your book tell us about it well
this is a book that as I like to say
starts with a hot air balloon ride and
ends with a record scratching cat very
interesting the the book as you just
said very eloquently is about
intersections of literature and media so
really looking not only at technologies
but also techniques of writing and the
ways in which they transform language
visual culture and ultimately literature
as well so the hot air balloon ride
refers to a print at the beginning of
the book and then the record scratching
cat is the kind of comical protagonist
of a should say narrator of a novel that
is called I'm a cat I am a cat and so in
the arc that the book tries to elaborate
over ten chapters it really looks at
sort of media history so the the
introduction of all of these new
technologies that that end in graph II
so telegraphy and photography and the
like and the ways that they were
instrumental in transforming the
Japanese modernity okay and what yours
are you specifically looking at from
went away so the Meiji Restoration which
is
often seen a sort of this watershed
event which is a real you know political
event as 1868 and goes until 1912 and my
book more or less tracks that period but
it's really beginning a little bit
earlier in the 1850s when Commodore
Perry and his so-called black ships
arrived in Japan and and sort of open up
the Tokugawa Shogunate to trade again
I'm not so much interested in the
politics of it but they bring with them
a model of the Telegraph and a
scaled-down version of a locomotive and
other forms of you know technology which
have a tremendous impression okay okay
and well I'd like to get to those actual
the technology in a minute but I'm
curious to know what led you to write
the book you know I I was very fortunate
and I graduated from college I had a
Fulbright for a year and I went to Japan
and that was really the point where I'd
finally reached a level where I could
read in Japanese and we were talking a
little bit earlier about you know with
Spanish and other languages sometimes
you you know students start reading the
newspaper in their second semester of
language study with Japanese it takes a
much longer period of time I can imagine
and so I was I was in Japan at nagua
University I was finally able to read
you know better than earlier and I kept
coming across a certain catch phrase
when I was looking at sort of the the
Meiji era literature and it sounds in
English something like to write things
down just as they are and this was sort
of the hallmark of realism and I found
this to be a you know kind of an
interesting catchphrase particularly
because it kept I kept encountering it
over and over again and when I started
to look at some of these questions of
technology one of the things I found was
that shorthand notation of all things
one of these sort of dead media are
forgotten media also had that same
catchphrase that that the shorthand
reporter you know should write things
down just as they are and it was a form
of man
you will recording prior to the advent
of mechanical forms of recording
so this precedes the phonograph it
precedes other you know forms of
capturing the voice and the like you
know typewriters and things like that
are also starting to be invented so for
me it was a bit of detective work it was
sort of how do you figure out this
puzzle of connecting the dots between
the technologies and literature the
aesthetics and the like and what was
most interesting to me is that
ultimately there was a very direct
correlation and so that's part of the
book that's sort of the heart of the
book okay interesting so how did you
connect the dots or how did you do your
research well I I was again fortunate I
was able to go back to Japan as many of
my own students at Yale are on a Japan
Foundation fellowship and I was able you
know by digging into the archives kind
of get elbow-deep in the dust and
crumbly books to find the original
copies of not only literature but also
transcribed pamphlets of a kind of
theatrical storytelling that was very
popular it's still very popular in Japan
but it was sort of the dominant thing in
in the sort of old downtown
entertainment district of Edo and then
you know later Tokyo and the shorthand
reporters were sort of prohibited from
recording some political forms of speech
because it was considered to be
controversial and the government was
trying to kind of keep a lid on the
people's democracy movement and so forth
so they were looking for another outlet
to sort of show off their skills and
this form of theatrical storytelling
became the occasion for them to sort of
show what they could do and so there it
was sort of in the preface ease of these
little pamphlets the scribbling that
almost looks like Arabic they're just
very simplified lines and circles and so
forth that that make up shorthand
alongside in Japanese is very
interesting
preparatory comments that would say
things like shorthand notation which is
a kind of verbal photography offers a
way of capturing speech in these new
ways and in fact this sort of became the
model for a new vernacular language to
come into into being it becomes a much
longer story which we don't have time
for today but Japanese in pre-modern
times had many different styles of
speech and writing okay and what we see
ultimately with the with the advent of a
new modern literature is something like
the vernacular style that is so popular
in Western languages and literatures and
that came about through the medium of
shorthand okay so let's look at some of
the technologies and and you mentioned
you know kind of the opening up of Japan
through Outsiders coming in and and the
thing some of the things that they
brought so let's talk about some of
those things and how big of an influence
was the West on the results that that
you were able to say yeah that's always
the sort of key question and I think
that for a lot of for a lot of scholars
that's been a question that either you
know there was either an endorsement of
the you know Japan was influenced by the
West Japan
you know reproduce those technologies in
its modernization and then there are
sort of others who adopt a kind of anti
colonial or nationalistic perspective
and want to kind of resist the notion
that Japan simply westernized I try to
thread the needle in a little bit of a
different way and so as I really worked
very closely you know again sort of
getting uh you know elbows deep into the
archives what I discovered is that a lot
of the reformers and innovators in Meiji
era Japan we're actually in dialogue
with some of their Western counterparts
so one of the chapters deals with a
fairly obscure figure named asawa Shuji
who went to boston to study and he
actually sought out Alexander Graham
Bell to teach him another one of these
sort of dead india forms called
double speech that Alexander Melville
Belle Graham Bell's father had had
created and he saw I wanted to correct
his pronunciation in Japanese sort of
lose his Japanese accent and the bells
father and son were really involved in
sort of what we would call today like
speech therapy had to help the deaf and
stammerers and the like to correct their
speech I am curious though why did he
want to lose his accent to what purpose
just to be I think understood better
okay but he but he was also an educator
and he was an educator also of the Deaf
and others and I think he was really
interested in this new form of script
that this was during a period in which
is a lot of reform even a generation
earlier people like Benjamin Franklin
had talked about adding and subtracting
letters from the alphabet but visible
speech was a totally different invented
alphabet and I think that it really
appealed to II Sawa in his ideas of how
to transform Japanese language education
but at any rate he learned it directly
from Graham Bell and when Graham Bell
invented the telephone he called asawa
and one of his other Japanese classmates
colleagues to come over to the house as
the story goes and apparently Japanese
was the second language used on the
telephone after English so there are
many such episodes with very high-level
contact between the Japanese reformers
and their their colleagues the first
Minister of Education from Japan
Moriarty was in dialogue with someone
named Whitney who was a thick a Sanskrit
is here at Yale mmm-hmm and a friend of
mine well Fleming is now at Santa
Barbara you know did some very
interesting research on that as well but
in my in my book what I talked about was
the idea that so Mori had this crazy
idea or that's how people often talk
about it of replacing the Japanese
spoken language of the form of
simplified English and everyone laughed
at him and thought he was crazy but what
I discovered is that
Mauri not so much in his direct
correspondence with whitney but looking
back to an earlier generation was
looking back to some of those reformers
who were saying for instance you know in
1789 that the United States should
create its own American English its own
national language on par with its
National Constitution so very often in
Japanese studies these type of
connections get lost and I thought it
was very important to really reconnect
Meiji Japan to its relationships with
the West so there rather than just being
a question of copying or resisting there
was a dialogue and so the book has a lot
of these sort of unlikely episodes that
I discovered in the process of doing the
research okay and what do you conclude
in the book what do I conclude questions
a lot of moving parts to this
well I'll refuse that if you wanted if
you had one thing you'd like your reader
to take away from your book what would
it be I would say that the technologies
that we use that we speak through also
speak through us so sometimes people who
view media history with skepticism say
things like well it's a form of
technological determinism that
technology is the historical agent for
everything I certainly don't believe
that but I do think that we should be
especially nowadays where we're also
invested in our technologies and
communicating through technology were
being recorded through technology so
it's very important for us to have an
awareness of that history and the way
that technology also has a history that
it has a past and some of these like I
used to joke when I was sort of just
starting this project you know there's
nothing sexier than shorthand no one
cares right
but there's a value to studying the
failures and the dead media and the ones
that have been superseded also because
therein lies some of the important half
steps on the way to getting to where we
are now right and that's the team yeah
it's important to think about that when
I think how how many people text now
this has a form of communication they
don't speak to one another everything is
texting and I am wondering what kind of
effect that will have on culture and
human beings in general down the road
yeah I mean there's so many terms that
that had been forgotten you know words
like stylus and tablet you know that
have been revived as our artists sort of
new digital technologies become more
prominent and in our lives and so forth
but even a word like emoji which
everyone knows now has made up of these
two Japanese words a for pictures and
moji for words and my book is very much
about changing word image relationships
even on the front cover if I can sort of
point to it here we have moveable type
at the top one of the innovations
brought in the late 19th century and we
have a carved wood block so we see two
forms of media sort of simultaneously in
this period of transformation
yeah and we're also in a period of
transformation here whenever you ride
the subway in New York City or in Tokyo
or anywhere else it's just interesting
to look around and see how many people
are still using paper right most people
myself included are usually on some form
of digital media
sure sure very interesting so this book
is out now yes it is okay good good and
you are now off and running on your next
project which is about pre-war Japanese
making their way to Brazil that's right
so tell us about that the immigration to
Brazil started in 1908 so we're still
technically in the Meiji period I go in
my book up until 1941 the onset of World
War 2 which is when the immigration
stops and then it will resume after them
where there are many Japanese going to
Brazil and why Brazil right so the
interesting quest
why Brazil is preceded by what happened
in this country it's a very timely
question because Japanese immigration
was first voluntarily restricted to the
United States and then by the alien
exclusion act by 1908 it was already
clear that the Japanese had to find a
new destination to send what they called
some disparagingly but itself critically
their surplus population Japan's
population really boomed from Meiji
onward so Brazil had this tremendous
coffee boom they the excuse me the land
around South Paulo state the interior of
são Paulo and the surrounding states of
Brazil were ideal for growing coffee and
they didn't have enough labor there were
a lot of immigrants coming from Italy
from Central Europe as well Japan became
another site for labor so of all of the
destinations for Japanese immigrants
Brazil was the largest there were almost
200,000 I believe the number was about
one hundred eighty eight thousand I went
to Brazil and today the largest number
of Japanese descendants outside of Japan
is not Hawaii it's not California it's
Brazil have they left any work on on on
Brazil in terms of because so many of
them were there absolutely I think you
know when we when we look at the legacy
of that immigration you know I should
say I focus on on the pre-war literature
which often deals with the hardships of
working coffee plantations and things
like that but in many ways the the
Japanese in Brazil also are seen as a
kind of model minority so the the
grandchildren and great-grandchildren of
these descendants of the Japanese are
doctors and lawyers and dentists and you
know elected office holders and all
kinds of things so it's it's it's a very
important part of the Japanese diaspora
that is I think not so well known in
this country right right I
I agree with that so hopefully people
read the next book as well and yes so we
have something to look forward to so
that sounds very fascinating as well and
thank you so much for being here with us
today and sharing some of your work
thank you for having me is my pleasure
for more information about Professor
Jacobo wits and his work please visit
our website at macmillan report yale.edu
be sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
[Music]